pues si tú lo mencionabas comenzó uno de
los capítulos más dolorosos de este
juicio por los atentados de la ciudad de
niza en julio de 2016 es el relato de
sobrevivientes en víctimas familiares de
las víctimas testigos socorristas que
vienen aquí a el tribunal de lo penal
del palacio de justicia de parís a
expresar a contar lo que vivieron
aquella noche son cerca de 300 los que
tomarán el estrado y son parte apenas
una parte de los cerca de 900 actores
civiles que forman parte que toman parte
en este proceso judicial en la jornada
de este miércoles escuchamos raúl
testimonios realmente devastadores quien
primero tomó la palabra fue la madre de
una joven que perdió la vida tenía 18
años pero para mí será siempre mi niña
pequeña dijo la señora por supuesto
desconsolada y tuvo el valor suficiente
para dirigirse de frente a los acusados
y decirles lo que hicieron fue cruel
ustedes son crueles por supuesto hay que
recordar que de esos 86
unas fallecidas 15 eran menores de edad
escuchamos también testimonios de alivio
como el de un bombero de 52 años que
acudió a socorrer a las víctimas y que
describió aquel escenario como una
carnicería me ha hecho bien que me
dejaran hablar aquí dijo el socorrista
que actualmente todavía sufre de estrés
postraumático y no ha podido recuperar
su trabajo debido a esta afección de
salud y como esos hemos escuchado en
varios testimonios realmente punzantes
que dan la medida del costo humano del
dolor que ocasionaron aquellos ataques
terroristas por su parte los ocho
acusados se mantuvieron de alguna forma
inmóviles no reaccionaron ante estos
testimonios se enfrentan a penas de
entre 5 y 20 años de privación de
libertad en un caso hasta cadena
perpetua no son considerados cómplices
ni actores esenciales sino que serán
juzgados por facilitarle al atacante las
armas y el camión con que acabó con la
vida de 86 personas tras atropellar a
cerca o más de medio millar en la probe
nada en el paseo de los ingleses en la
ciudad de niza en 2016